[Aplausos]
[Música]
moçambique regista um crescimento em
cerca de 7%
vou saber que registou um crescimento em
cerca de 8%
essas foram as notícias que ocuparão as
nossas telas pelo menos já tem uns
quatro anos atrás e também era dito
mesmo em relação à áfrica áfrica
acrescenta cerca de 5%
e tudo isso nos animava acredita que a
partir do crescimento é possível
alcançar o desenvolvimento e
desenvolvimento é tudo o que nós mais
queremos
e quando se fala em desenvolvimento já
temos uma noção de quem é o desenvolvido
e nós queremos ser igual àquela que o
desenvolvedor a gente se anula como
povoa a gente não consegue escrever
dentro das nossas experiências
a gente não consegue prever no nosso
território estamos sempre incompletos
queremos sempre ser outro existe
inclusive alguém que diz que sempre que
a gente viaja para um lugar sagrado
dentro de moçambique que a gente vai
encontrar um amigo ao time no lugar
maravilhoso nem parece meus amigos
porque mostraria que a desgraça saber
que aquele lugar do inútil
essa idéia que a gente produz ea questão
que a gente coloca é porque a gente
pensa assim
porque é que isso está desse jeito
nesse momento eu penso que é fundamental
que a gente aperta o cinto porque
faremos uma viagem longa que vai começar
no século 16
coloque os capacetes também é por
questões de segurança não está com vocês
um certo povo resolveu sair do seu
território e veja que elas aquelas que
dominou denominou de viagens de
descobrimento
assim começou porque havia uma grande
missão que era missão de evangelização
povo conhecer um deus ele disse nós
precisamos reproduzir ou enviar esse
deus em todo o mundo
é necessário que a gente faz lista para
que todo mundo conhece evangelho era
deus judaico cristão e assim começou a
jornada tudo aquilo então que não
conhece deus é obrigado a conhecer eram
os processos que por vezes envolviam de
utilização mas também violência
todo mundo tinha que conhecer a deus
porque esse é o deus verdadeiro o deus
que salva se você não obedece não ser
vencer de forma vai pro inferno é e até
hoje a coisa continua então procure
conhecer a cantora uma nova peça e assim
o ritmo prevaleceu infelizmente até hoje
tudo o que você acredita tudo que você
pratica todas as outras formas de
espiritualidade é inútil
essa técnica é macumba e feitiçaria
magia negra
o mesmo povo no século 19 encontrou uma
outra retórica do poder
denominou de civilização esse povo era o
civilizado e todo o resto do mundo não
conhecia não era civilizados e para que
você fosse um cidadão do mundo mello
você precisava adquirir características
desse povo
um segundo momento de anulação aconteceu
chegou no século 20 e descobriu-se ou
aprofundou ser a democracia
todos nós temos que ser democrático
vocês não são estranhos de olho em vocês
transferir nossos amigos vocês têm que
ser democratas se vocês não foram vocês
não serão nossos amigos e como nós
queremos tanto amamos tanto ser amigos
de luz nos estruturarmos nós
reformulamos temos que estar amigo dele
vamos mudar isso acabou de ficar tudo
isso direitos humanos olha olha até uma
nova palavra que nos encontramos em um
acidente mas não entenderam nos
respeitam nós conhecemos o homem nós
valorizamos a mulher nós valorizamos
todos os companheiros e companheiras
sérgio respeitador de vila de gente
muito bom
se vocês não respeitaria não estarão na
lista dos bons amigos
nós conhecemos o valor nos respeitamos
completamente bom nós fazemos as guerras
nós entramos no iraque podemos aceitar
mas tudo bem não é em defesa dos
direitos humanos
aí a gente a gente respeitar direitos
humanos que às vezes viola direitos
humanos para preservá-los
veja só que contradição né elas violam
as leis humanas para preservá-los
esse povo tão maravilhoso que mesmo a
gente vendo toda essa gente css é 130
mesmo durante uma exatamente essa
inclusive é fundamental também às vezes
violado
é assim a gente caminha o mesmo povo diz
olha nós somos desenvolvidos e mais uma
vez a gente tem 61 incompletos é o ideal
nós precisamos disso é isso que nós
precisamos na nossa vida
esse povo desse mais uma vitória nos
carros para que vocês consigam atingir
isso algumas coisas precisam ser feitos
fortaleça a democracia portanto essas
duas edições privatiza abras para o
mercado internacional
ok a brincadeira abertura foi assim que
a gente conseguiu combate à corrupção
constantemente você jogou muito combate
a votar
sabe porque a gente chegou a ser agente
as maravilhoso nós não sabemos que essa
coisa de roubo nos gente fina a gente
maravilhosa entender assim eles
constroem um mundo e mais uma vez a
gente sente incompleto tudo isso que
esse povo de jesus só nós e de regulação
eo que ela está naquelas patamar que a
gente conseguir a desejava e que foi
resultado de uma série de trajetória é
mentira
temos que reconhecer ele não foi não
cresceram ou não desenvolveram um termo
instituições fortes
as restrições que eles dizem que são
fortes foram resultado do processo
não estou dizendo que temos todas as
condições para a gente metendo
vamos fortalecer instituições mas o que
nós não podemos é assumir a retórica que
esse povo aqui hoje para continuar nos
colocar em situação subalterna
esse povo ele não cresceu não
desenvolveu privatizando não cresceu
abrindo os mercados não são mercados
muito fechado e até hoje nós percebemos
que são fechados procura exportar certas
coisas para o país delas
eles são um trecho incluindo pessoas as
únicas pessoas que podem circular pelo
mundo todo são anos nós temos muitas
restrições ea gente pode ver agora com
essa crise
a imigração é uma situação de fechamento
total das fronteiras
precisamos nos reinventar
precisamos nos conhecer como povo
precisamos construir nossos próprios
pilares
modelos áfrica moçambique que já se
mostrou bastante espertos e na
importação de modelos
nós precisamos fazer uma ruptura nós
precisamos construir a partir de dentro
nós precisamos olhar para nossas
condições e possibilidades e pegar cada
uma das coisas que está ao nosso redor e
construirmos a partir de deus não estou
dizendo que nós precisamos nos fechar
completamente ao mercado internacional
não precisamos nós precisamos nos fechar
completamente o ocidente o mundo abriu
se mais que é impossível mas também na
obra se demais a ponto de você não ser
reconhecer no seu próprio território
nós precisamos superar o dilema do pato
talvez vocês não conheçam o dilema do 4
eu vos apresentar o pacto voa mas vou
amá-lo mecânica mas cada mala
nada mais nada mais nada mas
infelizmente ter sido a figura
característica da nossa sociedade falou
dessa vez nada mais a sério na próxima
vai dar certo
vamos avançar não foi dessa vez não vai
mais avançado e felizmente aqueles que
nos respeitam
aqueles que nos impõe de certa forma nos
propõem modelos nos impõe propõe às
vezes tudo misturado impõe propõe a ser
montada quando após a falha o culpado ou
os culpados não são erros não é a
receita ou seja que tomar vocês olharam
você não sabe nunca é o problema das
receitas que eles passam pra nós
companheiros e companheiras não existem
soluções e ocidentais para problemas
africanos
[Aplausos]
as mudanças que a gente precisa as
mudanças que a gente almeja
são mudanças que tem que botar a partir
do nosso contexto a partir de longe
nós precisamos olhar para nós nós
precisamos olhar para as nossas
necessidades nossas condições e
procurámos construir um outro mundo
possível
esse mundo pode brotar eu acredito que
já começou a brotar em cada um de nós
nós podemos fazer diferente sabe a ver
se a gente olha para grandes lideranças
a nível do mundo ea gente deixa o fla
não sicrana conseguia pensar para além
do seu próprio tempo
talvez a gente não consiga pensar para
além do nosso próprio tempo
mas se a gente pensar no nosso tempo
carinhosamente a gente pode fazer
grandes transformações nesse país ea
geração vindoura dirá que houve uma
geração da ruptura uma geração que não
aceitou a continuidade
uma geração que não se conformou em ver
as coisas do jeito que estava
essa geração sou eu e só você não
deixamos para os outros há uns que
deixaram pra nós não deixamos para o
outono legado
procure fazer transformações procure
fazer diferente
para isso temos um desafio muito
fundamental para um povo que foi
colonizado para um povo que foi
escravizado há muito da essência desse
povo que se deslocou
precisamos resgatado como africanos como
moçambique carlos se pergunta quem é
você não tenha vergonha de si seja você
seja africana a responsabilidade de
mudar essa áfrica esse país é sua
os países que a gente admiram o estágio
em que eles estavam foi fruto da entrega
de luz não uma entrega romântica não
vamos dramatizar porque já houve um
processo de exploração muito profunda e
isso vale a pena assinalar o que eles
nunca nos dizem é que para estar em um
estágio em que estão eles colonizaram
pilharam escravizaram nós não veremos
por esses caminhos
nós podemos construir com outros
caminhos a menos que respeita o outro na
sua diferença caminhos que respeitam a
diversidade caminhos solidários
pra cá outra por outro lado nós podemos
encontrar o nosso parceiro nossa
parceria é agregar 0 amigo vamos
construir junto é bonito ver o juventude
empreendedora sua juventude a precisar
do nosso fortalecimento
se a gente não pode construir algo então
fortalecemos que está a construir a
gente pode ir ao encontro da senhora que
vende no mercado
a gente poderá ficar ao lado da pessoa
que faça uma produção muito local muito
concreta e fortalecer essa economia a
gente não consegue reconhecer muitas
vezes na produção local com todo momento
quer continuar a importar cultura começa
na china faz micro
enquanto a gente não conseguir fazer a
grande ruptura
nós podemos fazer cultura a partir de
pequenas coisas a partir de um pequeno
detalhe à parte da roupa que você veste
a partir do produto do cabelo que você
usa falar da roupa que eu visto como
vocês podem ver estou muito maravilhoso
muito lento
obrigado
foi um jovem que fez essa capulanas
estampa muito maravilhosa ele produziu
pra mim esse cabelo que está muito
maravilhoso eu sei vocês concordam foi
alguém que me passou os produtos que ela
produzir localmente e talvez você
conheça ou alguma e se você não conhecer
você pode buscar conhecer essa pessoa
vamos fortalecer como o povo não
esperemos com que os outros nos
fortaleçam
eu fico um pouco em como dado cada vez
que acontece uma tragédia em áfrica
a gente espera a solidariedade dos
acidentes ou a comoção e seletiva a
mídia nunca olha pra longe
nós não precisamos dela olhemos nos
tornaremos a minha solidariedade para
com a somália a minha solidariedade para
com o povo do meu lado é fundamental um
povo que escravizou que colonizou já te
mostrou de todas as formas que ele não
te ama não espera o amor de kent
violento ao longo dos tempos
[Aplausos]
estamos assistindo é uma relação nociva
uma relação violenta precisamos
construir uma outra relação é você amar
porque o contexto é você se perceberá
africano e podemos construir junto a
áfrica está na nossa responsabilidade a
áfrica
ver de cada um de nós a comoção em algum
problema tem que partir de nós a solução
dos problemas devem também partir de nós
é um dever que deve ser levado avante
por cada um de nós
por mim por si companheiros
eu quero que a gente hoje daqui a um
tempo em que a gente diga nós somos uma
geração de ruptura
eu quero que a gente olhe os nossos
filhos ou a próxima geração hoya e diga
que é uma geração que não se curvou a
uma geração que fez diferentes
tenho orgulho de fazer parte dessa
geração
tenha orgulho de fazer parte desse
processo
alguns caminhos eu penso que podem ser
traçados
o primeiro caminho é o sentido de
pertença conhece a ser tenha um sentido
de pertença com o território em que você
habita reconhece dentro desse território
à mercê território e diga as mudanças
que eu preciso nesse território estão na
minha responsabilidade mas não
singulariza pega o seu parceiro pega
alguém que agrega e construamos
coletivamente é responsabilidade
coletiva
vamos ler autores africanos
vamos conhecer como o povo vamos ler
escritores escritórios nos americanas
que fazem rupturas que lê partilhou os
que conhecem o nosso contexto não alguém
que sempre nos doeu a partir de fora
vamos construir as nossas próprias
narrativas já falaram muito de nomes já
escreveram muito sobre nós tomemos a
responsabilidade de falar de nós tomemos
a responsabilidade de fotografar a longe
vocês já viram que quando eles
fotografam sempre fotografando de graça
é como se a áfrica fosse desgraça deus
total acontece gera sua miséria
reconheçamos que ela existe temos que
superá lo mas também mostramos o que nós
temos de melhor como povo
procuramos fazer o cultura mais uma vez
mais uma vez eu digo que é um mundo
possível
esse mundo está dependendo de cada um de
nós nesta sala
mais uma vez repito nós podemos ser a
geração da ruptura não pula eu aprender
o osso lu o soul é uma palavra que
demonstra fortalecimentos viva um estou
contigo um acredito eu quero gritar aqui
nesta sala e quando eu disser ou sou eu
gostaria de ouvir cada um de vocês
dizendo oh solou solosolo podemos fazer
isso nós saber que o solo africa o solo
todos os primeiros da terra o sono
respeito às mulheres
respeito os games respeito de todos
aqueles tão diferente de vocês
construamos um outro mundo
respeitemos cada um na sua diversidade o
processo de desenvolvimento seja lá o
que for
ele precisa de respeito ao outro na sua
diferença
continuamos respeitando obrigado
[Aplausos]